All right. Yes, guys. Welcome back to
another one. And today I'm going to be
showing you how you could have made
money last week from the markets using
this ICT silver bullet strategy and
system. So let's get straight into the
video. So firstly, we're looking at the
key factors of the system. And the key
factors are one, you need to be inside a
macro. Second, you need to have a
liquidity sweep. So an actual sweep of
liquidity, you know, that could be a
five or 15 minute low. or you're looking
at key session liquidity such as London
highs, Asia highs, London lows, Asia
lows, these type of points. And then
you're looking for a market structure
shift after on both assets. So that
being uh NASDAQ and the S&P 500. And
then after a shift in market structure,
you want to see an inverse of an order
block. An inverse. So if you're looking
for longs, you'd want to see a bearish
order block get inversed. Or if you're
looking for shorts, you want to see a
bullish order block get inverse. That
will turn it into a mitigation or a
breaker block depending on if the
previous short-term high got taken or
not. Then with that inverse order block,
you want to see it paired with a Fav
value gap. And that F value gap is going
to be your point of entry for when you
take the trade. And then along with all
of this, you need to have an aligned
bias. So if you're looking for longs,
you need to have bullish bias. If you're
looking for shorts, you need to have
bearish bias. Simple as that. Tap on the
entry, you're in. So that is the overall
system here. We got it down 1 to six.
That's a brief explanation of what it is
you're actually looking for. So now
let's hop on the charts and see what you
could have done. Okay. So what we can
see here coming into the secondary macro
I have my timings down as London time.
So that would be why it's a little bit
different. However, this is 10:45 11:15
a.m. New York local time. So up here at
these points of buy side, I have a 5m
minute swing high marked out. That would
be where the trade gets invalidated as
that is a super buy side. As we said
with the New York open high, we can see
here that price has swept multiple
points of sell stops. So this would be a
valid point of a sweeper sellside side.
We can also see that on the S&P 500 that
if we mark out this swing low both
assets that the S&P 500 has actually
swept this point and ENQ hasn't. So that
would be a bullish SMT between the two
assets which is you know it's not a
compulsory confluence with this model.
However, it does help build the
narrative behind the trades that we are
taking. So, we can already see here
we're getting a shift in market
structure above both these swing highs.
And what do we notice? We notice that
this is a bearish order block that gets
inversed and the recent short-term low
got taken. So, this would become a
breaker block once it gets inversed. And
we can see we're getting a shift on ES2.
So, now we just need to wait for a macro
entry. So, we've got a FEL gap paired
with the breaker, but we just need that
entry inside a macro. So, price got very
close to tapping that swing high, but we
didn't get there just yet. making the
entry if we get it inside macro valid.
So this is tapping inside of that fali
gap paired with the breaker on both ES
and NQ. None of the gaps have got
inversed. So the model is still
completely 100% valid. So I'm going to
be taking a long here. I'm going to run
my stops at the short-term low for 51
points
and then going for a flat 1 to 2 RR.
And there we go. So at the time of this
trade, we have a bullish bias using
imbalances. We've got a shift in market
structure on both assets. We've got a F
value gap paired with the breaker block.
We haven't taken the 5minute swing high,
which means buy side is still there to
be taken. So this is a completely 100%
valid textbook model to be taken. We
have a bullish SMT between the two
assets. So let's see how this trade
plays out. So we can see as of now those
confluences are still getting respected.
Price now goes up and takes out the
first short-term high. So once we take
that first short-term high, that is
where you're going to trail stops to the
recent swing low. There's our recent
short-term low, taking off the majority
of the risk on this trade. So I wouldn't
be going break even here. Just as of
yet, we can still see a potential
possibility of price reacting off these
bullish confluences. We have a bullish
order block and we have a bullish fal
gap for price to react off. So, I'm
going to see if price does respond off
those points.
And there we go. Price taps into the
gap, goes higher, and then we see on the
S&P 500, it takes out this high, which
would be a bearish SMT against the
trade. And it's 50% of the way between
our entry and TP. So, this is where I
would go completely risk off the table
and break even. So, let's see if this
runs up to final TP.
And there we go. So that would be our TP
smashed inside of macro. My entry was
actually a bit higher which meant I had
to target a bit higher. So I actually
got stopped out in a profit for around 1
hour. This was a 2hour profit right here
that I've shown you guys and that would
be an example of it. However, in the
actual trade, we can see that price
comes down and I got stopped out at this
area here. That's where I got stopped
out. So I got stopped out for a 1 hour.
So that was the first trade
that we took inside of the second air
macro on Thursday. All right. Yes, guys.
So coming into the lunch macro now.
We're just going to quickly mark this
out. So we're coming into the lunch
macro. Now we're currently in the middle
of a range here between points of buy
side and sell side. So what you'd simply
do, we've gone to the 15minut time frame
or the 5m minute, and you'd mark out the
most recent 15-minut swing high and low.
So as we come into lunch macro, price
sweeps this point of sellside. We can
see that ES has failed to actually sweep
this point. So that's currently a
bullish SMT between the two assets. The
next step would be now as we're inside a
macro would be to get a market structure
shift.
Okay, so there we go. Price has shifted
structure on both assets. We can quite
clearly see above this swing high on
both NQ and ES. And what do we see has
been inversed in the process of this
shift bearish order block. So this
bearish order block right here gets
inversed. And then what do we notice
about this bearish order block? It gets
inversed. And what's it paired with?
Fair value gap. This gives this fair
value gap actual context. What do we see
on ES as well? A gap. A gap paired with
a inverse bearish order block. So both
assets are correlated very nicely. If
you go to the 5minut time frame, we can
see we have a 5minute high resting above
just here after the shift. That's three
short-term highs out. So this would be
your invalidation high. Price got very
close to that point. So if it did take
that point, it would have invalidated
the trade. However, it didn't. So, it's
fine. I'll now be looking for an entry
for longs of this valley gap. Just a tap
of first presented and we'd be in. And
there we go. So, price taps us in for a
long. And this is where I'm going to put
down a long position tool. I'm going to
run stops at a short-term low for 28
points.
Like so. And then for a flat 1 to 2 RR.
All right. There we go. So already we
can see price has flipped in the same
candle as our entry and it's taken out
the first short-term high. And in the
process of taking this first short-term
high, it's actually 50% of the way from
our entry and our takeprofit. Therefore,
this is valid for you to go break even.
So risk completely off the table as we
got into this trade. So now we'd want to
just see an acceleration in price.
Bang. And there we go. So that's another
two hours secured inside of this day of
the lunch macro. Now, the reason why I
wouldn't target the full draw. Yes, it's
a 4.2 RR, but firstly, all I really need
is a 2R. And if you look on the 5m
minute time frame, this is what I
noticed on the day is that it's actually
presented a model for shorts on the
5minute time frame. So the draw for this
long position would be this 5minute
imbalance and then I would expect price
to react off of this imbalance which is
why I wouldn't want to hold a long
throughout this point cuz it's basically
a 50/50 chance on if price is actually
going to accelerate through it or come
back off. Now why would you risk the
rest of the position on that one
possibility that it may go higher when
you've already secured it too far? It
makes no sense. So if you actually take
a look at what price then does it would
have come all the way down to your entry
and taken you out. So I actually closed
as soon as price tapped into this
imbalance on the 1 minute time frame on
ES. So I secured around a 1.8 profit
instead of a flat 2R but I still secured
around 2.8R on the day from these two
trades. Although right here you see was
4 R. I secured 2.8. And during the live
market conditions, you know, you can't
really go back and cherrypick precise
entries and stuff like that. Things are
going to happen and uh you know, you
just got to deal with what you deal
with. Like in terms of entries, a couple
points can actually vary your RR. So
therefore, your stop placement, your
takeprofit, and that's why in the first
trade, we were very close to a 2 R, but
it didn't hit. Whereas in the first
trade on when we're back testing here,
uh the entry was better. So therefore,
the 2R actually got hit. So yeah, but I
hope you guys have enjoyed this video.
If this video was helpful to yourself,
then make sure to drop a like and
subscribe for more videos. I'm dropping
content every single day. And if you
want to get involved with me personally,
then you can join the free Discord in
the description. And I will also give
you options to access the VIP Discord
where I stream live every single day.
And I also do one-to-one mentoring where
you can also apply too. Or you can reach
out to me on DM, whichever works for you
best. We'll be holding a live call on
Sunday. Every Sunday I hold a live
weekly call inside the free Discord. So
if that's something you do want to get
inside and you want to ask me questions
personally, feel free to do so. So I
hope you guys have enjoy this video and
I'll catch you in the next one. Peace.